[Music]
hey before we get into this highlight
clip we just want to let you know we're
doing a live show from the ship july
29th
momenthouse.com tinymeatgang tell them
what we're doing we're doing it's going
to be so much fun we got dj's head from
spock we got a live
that's cringe we're doing a new cody
noel do we're premiering it no one's
ever seen it we learned how to sword
fight it's [ __ ] insane yep and we got
some sketches that we made too
and two hours or more of us just riffing
and yeah
might have some special guests drop by
all around good time
so yeah come join us it's going to be
it's going to be awesome and
you know just so you all know once the
show happens it'll be available for 24
hours
after the show happens so in case you
bought a ticket but you miss it you can
still watch it for the day after but
after that
this finito is gone so uh make sure you
tune in
july 29th it's gonna be a good time
moment house dot com slash tiny meat
gang
so yeah so you might even share what
happened so you might have seen a
statement from faze where they
you know they suspended a couple people
yep um
it was phase k
they suspended jarvis nikken and tico
and k i think what phase k was like
removed i think k
and jarvis are brothers believe i don't
know
but and it's because they were all
shilling coins so they were showing this
coin called save the kids coin
and man i'm not even gonna tell this
as good as coffeezilla tells it if you
don't know what coffeezilla is man he's
got a youtube channel this dude
is right there goes into the trenches on
crypto scams and
it's like he puts in so much effort man
it's it's dope
so he has this video i watched not a
second of it was boring
and you know not to butcher it but
he does some digging where he kind of
cross
ref he he figures out through twitter
how
these people are promoting these coins
right right
and they typically what they do is like
oh i'm giving away a certain amount of a
coin and then people will tweet their
addresses at them [ __ ] mistake
because he's able to use that to
cross-reference oh okay
where they're getting the money from
yeah so cool someone sent you money yeah
and then he just cross-references the
date so he figures out a couple of
people's wallets
uh specifically i think he discovers
jarvis
face k and then i think tico or the
other dude basically he kind of
concludes that
in the past it doesn't seem like jarvis
or anyone else or this other kid
are perpetual pump and dump kids this
seems to be like the first time they've
done it because he's looked at their
wallet history okay and the other
projects they've promoted when you look
at their wallets they're
pretty intact it's like they buy some
they sell some there's no egregious
movement
he's like but when you get to phase k's
wallet it's dumps every single time
and if you go back and look at what he's
promoted and then you look at his wallet
he's dumping
hard and how much is he making so that's
one aspect where
he processes the numbers as jack [ __ ]
is it they're doing this for like 40 or
50 grand a pop
yeah like that i mean that's they're
doing it like every week
it's pretty good money i mean that no
that sorry but in crypto land maybe not
i just landed that's not a lot of money
in exchange for your entire reputation
right but like they don't think they're
doing anything wrong i think that's part
of it
so so phase k kind of pleads ignorance
right okay
and that's where coffee zilla's video is
really interesting
because the way it looks is not only is
it not ignorant
because like he has a past of it but he
digs down into like
he gets into this discord call with like
the developer of the save the kids coin
who basically comes across like a fall
guy okay who was like a developer who
was brought on and then he was named and
then like people are like oh yeah
if you're mad like take it up with lucas
okay so then this dude
exposes like one you know there's like a
lot of
influencers in on this like [ __ ]
summer rae rice gum
yeah yeah and so this kid lucas cops to
like you know
oh there was like a massive group chat
where
i was in with all the influencers and
they were really nervous about this
anti-whale mechanism so the coin
originally had a built-in
mechanism that would prevent you from
selling more than one percent of your
position in 24 hours
okay to stop people from dumping it
the night before it launches they make a
change to the contract and it goes from
24 hours to one minute who makes a
change
it's just it's in the like i oh no it
was the developer lucas
he had to do it and he was like yeah i
made that change that's what i was told
to do i was hired to do it i was just
doing my job like
oh so somebody that was so somebody that
was responsible for getting the
influencers involved
probably was like pressured by them to
change it so here's what's crazy is
there's like an obscure character named
manny
and coffeezilla kind of puts two and two
together
and sam pepper has been involved in a
lot of these and he's driving a lot you
know
in the crypto world people don't like
sam pepper because like i guess he shows
these scams pretty often
i can't verify that you know whatever um
i take kafizul's word for it though so
lucas when he's bringing bro he's being
brought onto the project by this guy
manny
as like a sign of like good faith that
these big influencers are going to be
involved
he sends lucas the developer a picture
of face k
holding up a piece of paper that says
lucas and manny basically verifying like
i know who these two people are
okay but that goes against like face
case thing about like i didn't know
i was pro i thought it wasn't bad right
it's like no no like you were way in
before
anyone huh cause like you were in on it
at the stage that the developer was
coming on so it's like
so then he probably had some hand in
getting the other influences
right because they would have pumped it
harder right so you must be in it deeper
than everyone else okay
so you know um
it's like you could you could reasonably
look at all the information and go
i don't know bro like i don't think you
can plead ignorance because
the the way all this lines up is like
you were in it pretty deep and a picture
of you like writing those two names is
pretty like
pretty obscure why the [ __ ] else would
you take that picture right
so this was kay who got removed he got
removed and he's
he's the only one that didn't get just
suspended yeah removed which means they
know he did something
worse than the other guys right and so
people have pointed out like faze have
done [ __ ] like this before
and there was like a whole telegram for
this coin it was a failed coin that was
like rebooted
the other big one was this dude joel
morris and he's heading up that thing
x-cad that like ksi and other people
have brought up oh yeah yeah and
coffeezilla added this dude as being
like a
serial dumper like yo this guy doesn't
serial [ __ ]
yeah you know this kid is filling
huggies with coins
so i don't know you you watch all this
and you're like one coffeezilla brings
up this amazing point which is like
bruh john mcafee got nailed by the sec
for doing this exact same thing
so what's to say you wouldn't like
arguably these people are
in some respects maybe bigger than john
mcafee yeah totally this is
just pump and dump schemes which is
illegal in any other market right yeah
yeah so the part that kind of like
i don't know feels gross to me is there
are like bigger whales in this scenario
like as far as influencers go you know
like rice gum summer rae whoever
and the only thing keeping them from
being
you know really like nailed to the wall
is no one knows what their wallets are
but could you imagine if there was a
list of wallets and like you could go
verify like all these
how can anyone like respect them at all
yeah how can
how can you even be a fan of someone
like that that would [ __ ] like
actually steal your money like that
that's crazy
because kids don't really get it i mean
so yeah that's the other thing i thought
was there's such a learning curve to
crypto still like if you
try to explain this to someone who
doesn't really get crypto they're like
uh
yeah what so like i don't this is like a
fake coin
and whatever i don't get it so they
stole money
that kind of sucks i was like no dude
like
i don't know stealing it from their fans
yeah because they're literally promoting
it to
the people that they're stealing it from
yeah and i mean the fact that they just
do it repeatedly and
i don't know bro it's just shitty yeah
and i think that this is the main reason
why
crypto this is one ceiling crypto has i
think
for the general public is
it's like it's just going to be
associated with this yeah like
for a while until they start regulating
it you know like like how stocks were
with like penny stocks and all that yeah
yeah yeah anyway what were you guys
saying here's a question though did they
save the kids
oh no what was the token for and
it was the beginning anyways like it was
supposed to be premised
that's the grossest part of the grossest
part yeah that's the most [ __ ] up part
ever
oh and they shot like this super high
high budget commercial for it
oh yeah so did it just tank
oh yeah immediately
that thing went into it and so like it
still exists
oh yeah but i mean it's not worth any of
what was put in
there's that clip of ricegum on twitter
being like hey if you guys want to scam
bang my line do you see that coffee
zilla like posted it was like hey this
is
price comes response to this right now
and he's like reading his chat and he's
like yeah man if you want
you guys want to scam bang my line that
was like a joke i guess and then
that was the only thing he said about it
it's like i don't even think they
realize like how
how [ __ ] they could this is or
potentially be
yeah if actually they like people go to
jail for this [ __ ]
i mean it's like it's just shitty
because even if you try to
bring up this subject of morality it's
like they just you know
oh whatever you're a hater yeah we're
just getting into the bag yeah
you just you're just trying this and
that's like nah man like you guys
aren't kids who are suffering for money
or
you're not like these are not people who
are in financially difficult positions
like they have access to a crazy fan
base
they get premier ad rates on [ __ ] just
given the organization they're a part of
it's like there's plenty of ways for
them to make money yeah the fact that
they choose this way
yeah this is lame man i mean is it kind
of the same as the gambling thing a
little bit
oh yeah yeah it's all kind of like in
the same vertical to me
yeah sure because it's like hey there's
people on twitter being like hey i'm
making stupid money betting or like uh
this coin this coin i'm making stupid
money on this right now it's only going
up it's only going up
yeah i mean these you know these people
aren't telling their fans to literally
gamble but like by
by processing they're being like oh my
god i just hit yeah for a hundred
thousand dollars
yeah people are like their fans are like
wait i i
could buy anything with that yeah money
like why wouldn't i just get on the side
and try to do the same thing
i mean you know like rice gum and like
other people have had no problem
promoting like loot crates
yeah but it's wild to me about that is
those loot crates were such
obvious scams and they did that and like
there was no real consequence for it and
you would think oh that's the end of it
but like [ __ ] like this bro
you could you could do time yeah which i
don't know maybe they think if they went
away for
i'm going away for getting the bag dude
yeah exactly
i'm going away because all these people
are haters my haters sent me
to prison for getting the bag yeah man
sorry that i'm making money
yeah nothing illegal about that i don't
know
i don't i want to sit here and get on
like some morality thing
but it's it's objectively [ __ ] up i
just don't know how
like they're gonna do this and then
brands will hit them up and be like yeah
we should we should definitely you know
mattel should definitely partner with
these people
yeah give them tons of money and put
them in you know
you know the spotlight and take
advantage of their audience it's like
aren't you guys supposed to be playing
video games
yeah that's great yeah how did this
whole thing start how did it end up here
yeah how did it end up you guys shilling
a
charity coin i mean you gotta
so then what happened with uh oh what's
the sand pepper one what's that one
no i mean just like people were bringing
up instances of sand pepper
like pumping and dumping and
uh i got it
yeah i think what's funny is like this
dude joel morris like
posting up like a medium article being
like addressing the situation
it's like there's we don't need to read
a medium article on this dude
yeah like and what is the article is it
like
pop it open it's like these were
legitimate things and
i mean obviously that's what he's going
to say
his cop-out is going to be some
somewhere in that vein
i did not get what did it say i did not
get it for free
yeah so that's a lot of their um
that's a lot of their rebuttal that's
the common thread is
oh i didn't get any for free i invested
my own money that's what a lot of them
say
it's like okay that's fine yeah
but if you if if you invest in something
that you believe in that's
part of it yeah like that's what you do
when you believe in something you put
money into it
so that's not like really uh an angle
out
yeah it's like oh i didn't get my
position for freeze like yeah because
you said you believed in it yeah it's
the part where you just took it out
immediately yeah so i just think it's
it's funny that's how hey look at this
[ __ ]
uh i was not involved in any of the
marketing plans i did not know the
project
existed two hours before i launched due
to it dumping 50 percent in two minutes
i panicked and started
so did he buy a bunch and then tweet
like hey save the kids i just i just i'm
in on this
or what i think so yeah yeah
is this guy an influencer i don't know
what the hell he is
okay oh no he said he didn't promote the
project anywhere
i'll tell you this he uh
he has no save the kids coins i can tell
you that
that he doesn't he does not save the
kids
it's so funny the beginning the thing
i'm investing in this because
we gotta you know save the kids it's a
good cause and then
it comes out and starts dropping a
little bit man [ __ ] these kids
i'm out of this [ __ ] [ __ ] them kids can
we bring up that commercial
i just think it's so funny now knowing
that which one
look at this commercial they did if it
still exists
yo entertainers just gotta stay away
from kids
they like they i don't know what it is
entertainers cannot
stop [ __ ] with kids literally and
you know financially just while we look
for this video
uh i don't know just search it up on
youtube
uh pedophile police
went crazy last week with who
they got you know drake from drake and
josh wait what
yeah what did he do he like you know he
pleaded guilty to like endangering a
minor
jesus christ so he's looking at two
years oh yeah i did see that cory in the
house got bagged up
yeah jesus christ
yeah no one respects the kids man i know
hollywood needs to just stay away from
the game
don't do crypto with the kids don't do
anything with the kids
man just leave them alone that [ __ ] is
let me see if i can find this man the
commercial is so funny too because they
are like
uh it's
ah they probably oh really
so i don't is it is it like no no did
this coin like tank and then i like all
it's like one of those ones where the
founders left
and they're like [ __ ] this it's not
working so they deleted everything and
that just like dipped yeah
and now the coin just exists and it's
just worth is worthless
yeah yeah it seems like it happens with
every single one and they go start a new
one
yep oh here we go here we go here we go
got it
look at this ah [ __ ] there's no audio
oh they're actually in it yeah the
commercial that's what i'm saying
oh my god whatever it's fine you get the
vision yeah yeah yeah
the visual is good enough like let it
play let it play just mute
this looks like chicken nuggets like
mcdonald's house or
commercial or like children's hospital
or something like that yeah you know
save the kids a bep 20 token
redistributing wealth to both
holders and charities and charities get
out bro
jeez
so yeah but you know
anyone else would just like look past
this and be like oh it was a mistake
he was you know everyone will you know
make excuses this [ __ ] it's just
this is whack man yep i mean shout out
to
coffee zilla though like his videos yeah
big shout out rushing it is not
shout out face jarvis anymore yeah yeah
i know
we messed up with that last time dude it
is now shout out coffeezilla
that is that is the goddamn truth
yeah that's crazy dang yeah
anyway sorry sorry for all the crypto
speak again but this is
not funny this is so fun to talk about
also because it's actually like
it's so so interesting no it's also such
a modern
issue and like scandal like yeah where
where even three years ago would anyone
have predicted like oh yeah you know
those kids from the
faze gaming team yeah yeah they're gonna
use crypto and to scam
16 year olds what the [ __ ]
what are you talking about